[Music]
we wanted to rethink food and create
something extraordinary introducing fry
carefully preserving color and texture
permitted almost elegant model yet we
combined multiple incarnations of oil to
create an all permeating substance we
like to call smart grease smart grease
allows the user to know exactly where
fry is or where it has ever been
fry enhanced food for the modern world
but that's not all
introducing nugget
nugget is what happens when machinery
meets meat when you look at nugget you
see not the contents inside you see the
breading outside that was intentional
inside this advanced piece of food we
can examine the complexity that makes up
this product to change the way we
experience chickens to change chicken
itself
oh and one more thing Mac we have
refined and refined and
refined basic ingredients
[Music]
the sesame seeds on the bun are there
because we put them there
the feel of the Mac is somewhere between
firm and soft
the people who are hungry enough to eat
the Mack all those who do
[Music]